good morning my name is Nick Dirk's I am
the vice president for the Arts and
Sciences and dean of the faculty at
Columbia and happily I'm about to
introduce someone who will make it clear
that your name doesn't have to be Nick
to be a Dean at Columbia it is my great
pleasure and privilege to introduce this
conversation between Nobel laureate
Orhan Pamuk and our new dean of the
School of the Arts Carol Becker carol
has come to us just at the beginning of
this month from the school of the Art
Institute of Chicago where she was dean
of the faculty and senior vice president
for academic affairs she brings not only
a wealth of leadership experience but
also an extraordinary dedication to
fostering artistic creativity and to
enhancing the role of the Arts and the
role of the artist in society as a
writer a cultural critic and educator
she will help the arts excel at Columbia
and in New York City bringing I think a
richer experience both to the RM MFA
students in the four divisions of
theater visual arts writing and film and
also for our undergraduates whose
experience of the Arts will be expanded
and enhanced under Carol's leadership
with research interests that range from
feminist theory American cultural
history and the education of artists to
South African art and politics she has
published numerous articles and books
including the invisible drama women and
the anxiety of change the subversive
imagination the artist society and
social responsibility zones of
contention essays on art institutions
and gender and surpassing the spectacle
we're delighted that Carol agreed not
only to come from Chicago to New York
but from New York to Paris to engage in
this conversation with Orhan Pamuk orhan
pamuk is in fact someone with a deep
connection with Columbia University
during three quiet years in the late
1980s when his wife was a graduate
student in the department of art history
Orhan occupied a Carroll and the upper
reaches a butler library and wrote what
is still one of his most important and
also most deeply personal books novels
the
black book it was this connection that
indirectly led to a regular appointment
just last year just in time of course to
host Orhan as he received the highest
global honor for his work as a writer
the black book is a stirring narrative a
mystery story of sorts a love story to
that explores in depth several Atomics
enduring novelistic themes among them
the question of personal identity the
protagonist of the novel searches the
urban landscape of Istanbul for his
vanished wife and her half brother whose
identity he eventually takes on writing
his newspaper column occupying his
apartment wearing his clothes this
doubling of characters takes place in
other novels at parks as well for
example in the White Castle where two
men exchanged life stories only to
exchange identities as well perhaps the
riddle at the heart of snow parks most
recent and most acclaimed novel is an
extension of the same question the
protagonist car enters and ultimately
disappears in a blinding blizzard in the
northern town of cars on the cusp of the
old Ottoman Empire where cause seems to
be searching for his own original
identity after years spent outside
Turkey in Germany where he was a
political exile perforce taking on a
different detached and Western of course
identity a poet who cared little for
politics he found himself nevertheless
caught in a blizzard of politics having
taken on the false identity of a
journalist to explore his interest in
the suicides of young girls over the
prohibition of wearing a veil Colin not
only found himself in the grip of the
storm but also caught between the stark
manichean worlds represented by
political Islam on the one side and the
post Ataturk secular state on the other
both worlds appear intolerant the
flipped sides of each other as the poet
finds himself inescapably engulfed by
political turmoil and danger life and
art are never easy to keep apart and
Paul MOOCs craft clearly springs in part
from his own experience of growing up in
a cultural milieu defined largely by its
position on the classical cusp of east
and west
even the Istanbul telephone directory
denominates the Bosphorus as the
boundary between Asia and Europe and the
doubling of identity has also perhaps
been the reigning national allegory of
modern Turkey Paul moocs writing is
clearly indebted to great European
novels and novelists starting perhaps
with Kafka think only of snows
protagonist name but is even more
profoundly influenced by dostoevsky and
other Russian writers themselves perched
on another kind of cognate border
between east and west but more recently
comics life took on a difference in more
dangerous mimetic character as he found
himself accused of impugning the
national character of turkey itself by
remarks to a journalist about the
histories of Armenians and Kurds in
modern Turkey suddenly seeking exile
Orhan came back to his other city New
York and took refuge in another Carol
this time in the upper reaches of the
Deutsche house on 116 street just to the
east of the main campus that's where he
was during the winter a snowbound winter
at that of 2005 and it was because of
this visit and the acquaintances that
were being nude during this time that I
met Orhan and was able to persuade him
to take the sanctuary of columbia as the
basis for a regular academic appointment
he was the first visiting fellow of the
Committee on global thought a creation
of President Bollinger's vision to make
Columbia a genuinely global university
and he's now a regular professor at
large in the arts and sciences each fall
days after coming to columbia last fall
he of course was awarded the nobel prize
a fact that was little known at the time
was that this was a convenience for us
since we were having a small visa
problem with Orhan and we needed a major
international prize in order to clear
the bureaucratic hurdles that being said
we all bast impact in the prize in the
glory it shed upon him and by extension
us and we are delighted that he
continues to be with us for his presence
reminds us that the university itself is
a sanctuary where ideas literature art
philosophy collide with life in the
privileged and protected spaces
of intellectual exploration and mutual
respect we're thrilled to have Orhan and
Carol as two of Columbia's newest
citizens and to have them here with us
in Paris please join me in welcoming
Carol becker and Orhan Pamuk